[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is shintaro okamoto i'm the
founder and creative director of okamoto
studio customize
chorus light asked me and my team to
think about what different unique things
we do with ice and
i wanted to really kind of focus on the
freezing process itself
right now i'm sitting in my freezer here
in my studio
in queens new york
[Music]
i always say not all alaskans played
with ice but i did
i started carving ice with my father i
think when i was maybe
12 13.
that's when my father first
entered a international ice carving
competition that the city of anchorage
hosted
and i was his partner
it was a really terrible experience
my job was
shoveling snow and scrap ice all night
but at the end the sculpture was
beautiful the response was amazing it
was a really beautiful thing that i
really kind of fell in love with
[Music]
trying to get rid of any kind of excess
soil
oh boy it's going to be really tricky
oh
i lost my rig
this is going to be easy
this is going to
suck
[Music]
nope
screen
screen
[Music]
change of plan
plan a didn't work plan b didn't work
plan c i think is
brilliant
if it works
don't touch it i don't want to do it
redo it
i've always seen ice as a time-based
material it's constantly changing
evolving it's that kind of embodiment of
time passing freezing item inside the
ice does
almost exactly opposite where he stops
the time
[Music]
all right so the ice been
freezing since uh yesterday
so it grew but a lot last night was nice
and cool i guess
[Music]
that looks great
we really work with the moments of
freezing and studying the process of how
ice is formed and how ice itself
really kind of comes to life
[Music]
there's a really beautiful dichotomy of
the cold trapping the best of the summer
within ice
i think my father is really chuckling
every day with different kind of things
that we do and and challenges we face
it's him who really
got me into ice and it's a
often a frustrating
cold
not the most comfortable things to work
with but the end result is always
mesmerizing and
i'm always looking for something fun to
do every day
you